debajo de este pedazo de tierra en
galway cerca de 800 bebés y niños
pequeños están enterrados fueron tirados
por las monjas de uno de los hogares
materno-infantiles de irlanda anacardo
cree que los restos de sus dos hermanos
pueden estar allí
me pregunto dónde están están muertos
están caminando por eeuu saben quiénes
son ellos saben algo de todo lo que está
pasando mientras nosotros estamos
traumatizados aquí viven en una
investigación oficial sobre los hogares
manejados por la iglesia católica desde
1920 hasta 1998 detalla las malas
condiciones y el aviso en esos lugares
en total nueve mil infantes murieron una
tasa de mortalidad del 15% y muchos
otros fueron dados en adopción
forzosamente en el extranjero el
gobierno se prepara para pedir perdón
oficialmente prometió dar una
compensación económica a los afectados y
exhumar algunos de los restos
tratamos a las mujeres
excepcionalmente mal tratamos a los
niños excepcionalmente mal teníamos una
actitud completamente distorsionada
sobre las
y la intimidad y las madres jóvenes y
sus hijos e hijas se vieron obligados a
pagar un precio terrible por esas
disfunciones fat actress thompson en el
pasado en irlanda quedar en embarazo
antes de matrimonio era visto como algo
profundamente vergonzoso las mujeres
eran catalogadas como pecadoras muchas
fueron escondidas en los hogares para
dar a luz y luego fueron separadas de
sus bebés cerca de 56.000 solteras y 57
mil niños pasaron por estos lugares
la iglesia católica aceptó que fue parte
de la cultura que estigmatizó a las
mujeres y le pidió perdón a los
sobrevivientes